- ♪ C'est presque au bout
du monde ♪
- "L'heure mauve", c'est
cette oeuvre d'Ozias Leduc
peinte en 1921.
C'est aet le titre de la nouvee
exposition de Nicolas Party,
un jeune artiste incontournable,
à qui le Musée des beaux-arts
NICOLAS PARTY, artiste visuel
- C'était l'idée d'entre deux
et de crépuscule qui me touchait
beaucoup et que... je trouvais
"L'heure mauve" fonctionnait
très bien.
♪ ♪ ♪
basé à New York, a puisé
dans la vaste coll
du Musée pour y sélectionner
des oeuvres de grands maîtres
les siennes.
- C'est de pouvoir
en fait, des oeuvres du passé
qui avaient été conçues de
justement, les voir de manière
anachronvoir comment
elles nous parlent du temps
présent, du temps futur.
les salles du pavillon Michal et
ornstein. Et le résultat
est à couper le souffle.
STÉPHANE AQUIN, dir. généréal
- Le tout fait vraiment oeuvreùu
on arrive dans le grand escalier
puis on voit la murale,uvre d'at
de Nicolas Party.
♪ Je caresse le souvenir
- Et pour ajouter à la magie,
apointe signe la trame
sonore de "L'heure mauve".
PIERRE LAPOINTE,te
- Je me suis dit, dans le fond,
faire exactement ce que
Nicolas Party fait, c'est que
je vais prendre une oeuvreue
de la chanson et je vais écriree
en réaction à ça.
Et ensuite, pour ales,
j'ai bien étudié chacune
des salles que Nicolas avait
montées et j'ai essayé de faire
des choi
- Les deux artistes ont exploré
le rapport qu'entretiennent
les créateurs avec la nature
- Je me suis rendu compte que,
comme dans l'histoire de l'a
pictural, en histoire de
la musique, aussi, on a
québécoise à travers la nature.
- Ce qui m'a marqué de beaucoup,
c'est cette forte présence,
de la nature et de l'histoire,
ation
des artistes et de la culture
canadienne avec le paysage qui
idéalisée, des fois, une
très conflictuelle.
- Nicolas Party a réalisé
sur place de grand
au pastel, son matériau de
prédilection.
les ailes d'un papillon.
En fait,
cette sensualité, c'est,
je crois, ce qui me touche
- Nicolas Party a commencé
sa carri graffeur.
Il est habitué aux oeuvres
éphémères. En octobre,
ses oeuvres créées au Musée
îtront poîtront poîtront poîtro.
Il faut donc profi au moment aut
où c'est encore l'heure,"L'heur.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,